foreign
of my country Pakistan is underwater
an exceptional Monsoon coupled with
flash flooding due to the accelerated
melting of the Himalayan glaciers has
led to devastating flooding
floods so destructive so all-consuming
that the adjective most frequently used
to describe them is biblical
the area of land that is underwater is
larger than Britain
over 33 million people are affected
stripped of homes and livelihoods
hundreds have been killed
and those that survived are now dying of
malaria
Dengue fever diarrhea
the crops that we planted have been
washed away
and our Fields will be waterlogged for
many months to come imperiling the
critical wheat planting season
Pakistan is in shock
and all it can look ahead to is food
insecurity
famine climate migration
and conflict
Pakistan needs tens of billions in
emergency relief funds and it needs them
right now
but I'm not here to talk about today's
crisis I'm here to talk about the way
forward
as the scale of Devastation becomes
apparent the sense of climate Injustice
is mounting
Pakistan emits less than one percent of
global greenhouse gases and yet it is
consistently among the countries most
vulnerable to disasters caused by
climate change
that vulnerability has been horrifyingly
laid bare over the last few months
calls are growing for the global North
to compensate the global South for the
fact that high emitting activities in
developed economies are leading to
catastrophic climate change linked
events in less developed countries
since the Industrial Revolution today's
wealthy Nations have benefited
economically from high emitting
activities
the G20 are still responsible for 80
percent of global greenhouse gas
emissions
the logic is simple
industrialized nations that have
profited from fossil fuel driven
development should be the ones to pay
the bill when climate disaster strike
poor countries such as mine
this idea is not new nor is it
particularly controversial
in 2009 developed countries promised to
mobilize billions in climate Finance to
support emerging economies
that funding has not materialized
and so the demands for reparations have
but let's be clear
developing countries are not asking for
charity
having polluted only marginally they are
climate creditors
and that credit is now due
as I said the logic is simple
but the politics are complicated
developing countries have not
consistently demanded reparations for
climate change linked loss and damage
many countries in the global South led
by India and China subscribe to the
catch-up argument
the notion that developing countries
should now be allowed their share of
pollutants and greenhouse gases in order
to build infrastructure and spur
economic growth
this reasoning envisions the West
curtailing emissions and bearing the
financial cost of the economic slowdown
while developing countries continue to
emit Build and Grow
it's a way of saying hey it's our turn
this catch-up argument is compelling but
it does not speak the language of
reparations
climate Justice is based on the notion
of not being punished for someone else's
bad behavior
it does not sanction more bad behavior
you cannot both demand reparations and
the right to emit
but many developing countries have yet
to engage in climate diplomacy
a process of reconciling the demand for
reparations with existing Security in
foreign policies
and so you'll see cases where some
government departments
are demanding climate Justice While
others are seeking foreign funding for
coal and gas projects
or pursuing defense deals with high
emitting Nations
it is difficult to have it both ways
and that's why demanding reparations
also means bringing forward a clean
Green Vision
one which includes leapfrogging the high
meting stage of Economic Development
into a more sustainable future
for countries like mine that means no
more poorly planned expressways or Elite
real estate developments dotted with
swimming pools or golf courses and
drought hit areas
because sadly it is true
that the scale of Devastation in
Pakistan and in climate calamities
elsewhere
it's not just the result of climate
change
but also a consequence of poor
governance
of inadequate planning the lack of
infrastructure corruption and the lack
of accountability
this is something the global South must
acknowledge
but this is absolutely not to place the
onus back on climate vulnerable
developing countries
no instead it is to say that the time
has come for the global North and the
global South to agree the terms of a
just transition
are we ready for a new social contract
within countries and between countries
One Way Forward is to adopt a more
expansive definition of reparations
this should take the form of funding for
emergency relief loss and damage
but it should also include technical
assistance adaptation planning
and the skills development needed to
tackle the climate challenge
developed countries should provide
funding but they should also provide
access to the green technologies that
can help countries such as Pakistan
catch up but without the high emissions
Pakistan is drowning
and its people are desperate
their present is your future
we need a new era of climate diplomacy
and we need a new recognition that we
are in this together
we can adapt mitigate build resilience
but only if we do it together
the logic of climate Justice is simple
let's make the politics simpler too
thank you
thank you so when I introduced you I
said that to the floods have not
received enough attention in the global
media but how are the Pakistani media
talking and Reporting about them
thank you for that question you know
we're just a month into the Declaration
of a national emergency and the floods
are already slipping out of the news
headlines in Pakistan I think we're
really suffering from the fact that the
24 hour news cycle does not know how to
tell this story a story so big a story
that requires you to connect the dots to
every other story you will ever tell
whether we're talking about food the
economy
uh insecurity domestic militancy there's
no story that can be told without also
telling the story but unfortunately I
don't think we have that media literacy
and the floods are already receding out
of our own headlines so what can we
expect from the international press well
is it uh hail already coming at least
Aid is coming but not enough and not
fast enough and uh you know Pakistan has
said that they need about 30 billion
dollars to help with the rehabilitation
and reconstruction phase and we're at a
stage where for example I think the UN
tomorrow launches a new appeal that's
for 600 million dollars so I don't think
that there will ever be enough Aid you
know we do need we need some of these uh
reparations we need a better plan for
how we're going to fund these kinds of
climate disasters but unfortunately even
before the money has started flowing
those questions have started you know
where's the money that's already gone
through gone who is tracking it what is
it being spent on and I fear that those
kinds of questions deter more funding
when actually it's the absolute need of
the r now I want just to put an image in
the mind of people here when we uh one
of our conversations you told me a story
about people in flooded areas going
around in small boats and hitting
structures underwater tell us about that
yeah so you saw the pick pictures that I
started with and you know I've been
seeing those and I haven't visited
myself the most badly affected areas and
it was only when I received a video from
a friend of mine who was out there
reporting in the field which showed her
in a boat going through what I thought
was a lake and then they started bumping
up against things and you realize that's
the top of electricity pylons and it's
the top of school buildings and it's the
top of petrol stations with the little
you know advertising symbol that I
really understood that my country is
submerged it is truly underwater and I
don't know how you come back from that
thank you for sharing this story and
thank you for your talk thank you
[Applause]